ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมน้องเหลี่ยม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
ที่คุยหัวเราะอะไรหัวเราะสองอย่างรถดีใจ
เจอน้องเรียมแล้วก็หัวเราะเอ้าวิวข้าง
หลังไม่ได้เปลี่ยน
เห็นนั่งนั่งอยู่ที่ไหนคะ
ตอนนี้ล่ะคะจริงๆนั่งอยู่ที่บ้านนะคะแต่
ว่าวิวข้างหลังเป็นเป็นเป็นวิววัด
ที่ญี่ปุ่น
วัดก็เลยบอกทำไมมีวิวอันนี้
ขอเปลี่ยนวิวได้ไหมคะได้ค่ะเหรียญเป็น
อะไรดีคะเปลี่ยนเป็นเป็นวิวดอกบัวแล้วกัน
ค่ะโอเคมั๊ยดอกบัวก็
มา
เตรียมไม่ได้เจอพี่เอ๋นนานมากมากไหมล่ะ
มากไหมนานๆมากไหมหรอเดี๋ยวนะสักครู่นะคะ
nana  Nan อ่ะคิดว่านานเท่าไหร่นะ
[เพลง]
เดี๋ยวสอนเดือนไหมคะ
ประมาณประมาณเราเจอกันครั้งสุดท้าย
วีดีโอนะไม่เห็นไหมเห็นคนเราเจอกันครั้ง
สุดท้ายครั้งสุดท้ายคือปีที่แล้วใช้ปี
เดือนอะไรนะ
ธันวาคมวาคมอ่า
ประมาณ
ประมาณซะ
ก่อน One  Piece มาตร
ประมาณประมาณ
28 ไว้ที่เจอกันครั้งสุดท้าย
ครั้งครั้งล่าสุด
เราเจอกันในหลายกลุ่ม
ห้าย 28 หรอ
28 นะคะอ่าครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋เจอกันวัน
สุดท้ายวันสุดท้ายก็คือ
28 น้ำประมาณ 28 เดือน
เดือนธันวาคมใช่ค่ะ 2,000  21 จนถึงวัน
นี้
วันอะไรนะคะคุณค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวัน
อาทิตย์นะคะ
วันที่เท่าไหร่นะคะวันที่ 6 ค่ะวันที่ 6
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ค่ะ
ไม่ใช่วกะลาไม่ใช่งอกอะลาคมขอโทษค่ะขอโทษ
นะนานจนลืมเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์
ปีเท่าไหร่คะปีค.ศปองคัน 22 ค่ะมี 2 คัน
22 ปีไทยค่ะปีพตเท่าไหร่คะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะผช
2565 โอ้โครเรียมมีรูเหไม่เจอเจอไม่เจอ
จริงๆ
ไม่มีไว้ได้ชัดทุกคนคู๋ยุ่งนะคะเองยุ่งกู
เอ๋
[เพลง]
พี่
ขอไปบ้านเพื่อนโอ๊ตภาษาไทย
ยุ่งรู้เหไม่อยู่บ้านครูเอ๋อยู่บ้านด้วย
แต่ไปท่านคุณแม่ด้วยไปบ้านเพื่อนไป
ช้อปปิ้งไป
ไปยุ่งแล้วก็มีคลาสตาก็ทำงานทำงาน
สอนด้วยไปด้วยเราก็มีปาร์ตี้
ก็
ยุ่งมากๆก็ไม่เจอน้องเรียมตั้งแต่อันนี้
ก็โอ๋
1 เดือน
กับเจ็บ
แต่มัน 1 เดือนกับ 8 วันเดือน 4-8 วัน
เหรอคะ 28  29  30  31
3 วันแล้วก็วันนี้กลับไม่เลข 5 วัน 8
วัน
หนึ่งเดือนใช่ไหมมกราคมเนี่ย
มกราคม
31 วัน
31 วันไม่เจอกันใช่ค่ะไม่เห็นแล้วก็
ธันวานี้ 3 วัน
กุมภาพันธ์ 5 วัน
ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะอ่า 1 เดือนกับ 8 วัน
หนู
คิดถึงไหมคะ
ถึงค่ะคิดถึงคุณเอ๋
เตรียมเห็นครูเอ๋โพสต์
เอ่อใน Facebook  A  Team ครีมแล้วก็กด
โพสต์ใน Facebook
เลี้ยงก็ไปกดไลค์
แล้วก็มาเรียกดไลค์ทำงาน
โรงเรียนจะเห็นปกติครูเอ๋ชอบโพส Facebook
แต่
1 เดือนโพสต์
1 วันแล้วก็หยุด
ไม่โพสต์ทุกวันใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนเมื่อก่อน
ครูเอกก็โพสต์ใน Facebook ทุกวันเหรอทุก
วันอาจจะดูอะไรแล้วก็แชร์อะไรอ่ะอ่านอะไร
กับแชร์ที่ Facebook แล้วก็ชอบโพสอาจสนุก
ๆคนเดียวคนเดียวก็โพสต์ตอนนี้ไม่มีมีเวลา
โพส
ไม่มีเวลาทำวีดีโอ
เพราะว่าครูเอมมีสอนใช่ไหมคะมีค่ะมีใคร
สอนเรียนผ่านไหมคะ 1  2
3  4
บางวันบางวัน 555 สาบางวัน 3  Class
หมูตอนนี้ครูเอ๋สอน
สอนคลาสอะไรบ้างคะ RB กินหน้ามีกินได้
อินเทอร์มีเดียทอ่าแอดวานซ์ writing กลับ
อ้ามีใครเวททาร์ต
เป็น conversation อ๋อบีกินเนอร์นี้ก็คือ
เป็นพูดสอนสอนพูดหรอคะกินได้หน้านัก
เรียนฟังหูฟัง on นักเรียนฟังแต่ว่า
นักเรียนพูดได้อ๋อ
ถ้าพูดภาษาอังกฤษนะคะ
พูดภาษาญี่ปุ่นนะคะ
เพราะว่าสัตว์สีพูดภาษาญี่ปุ่นได้ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้เกลียดพูดพูดภาษาญี่ปุ่นไม่ได้เหรอ
คะเดี๋ยวค่ะนิดเดียว
นักเรียนพูดใช่ไหมคะภาษาญี่ปุ่นครูเอ๋ฟัง
ไม่เข้าใจนักเรียนก็วาดรูป
เหมือนกันครูพูดนักเรียนฟังไม่เข้าใจครู
ก็มีนี่ใช่ไหมคะอ่ะมี
มีแบบนี้นี่
ขอลบก่อนนะคะ
หรือ
ครูบอกพระอาทิตย์นักเรียนบอกพระอาทิตย์
อยู่ในพระอาทิตย์
ครูก็
วาดรูปอาพระนทิพย์และ
วาดรูป
พระอาทิต
า
นักเรียนก็เข้าใจพระอาทิตย์แต่ถ้าครูเอ๋
นักเรียนพูดภาษาญี่ปุ่นไม่เข้าใจนักเรียน
วาดรูป
[เพลง]
นักเรียนพูดได้แต่นักเรียนพูดภาษานัก
เรียนครูพูดภาษาของครู
งูวิกัน
คุยกันนักเรียนก็วาดรูปครูก็วาดรูปอ่ะๆ
คลาสของกูเอ๋จะแบบนี้ถ้า
เรา
ลูกเอ๋บอกว่าไปช้อปปิ้งออกไปช้อปปิ้ง
รู๋ไปช้อปปิ้งซื้ออะไรคะซื้อหรือเปล่า
ไป R บางวันขาย 2
Fuji  Supermarket
บางวันอ่ะอะไรนะเยาวราช
นักเรียนคะเยาวราชรู้จักไหม
เยาวราชเป็น
เป็นเป็นตลาดคนจีนให้
ขอโทษนะคะคุณจี่จริงๆไม่ต้องทำปลาเนาะกู
เอกตาคนจีนอยู่แล้วคนจีนไทยจีน
ที่ประเทศไทยเรียกว่าเดี๋ยวว่ะราชทั่ว
ประเทศนักเรียนจะเรียกว่าไชน่าทาวน์ล้า
ได้ค่ะประเทศไทยอ่ะเยาวราชอ่ะ
สวยมากค่ะเยาวราชสวยมากเรียมชอบไปเยาวราช
ไปถ่ายรูป
คู่เลี้ยงม้ามากรุงเทพฯ
เดือนนี้เดือนนี้เดือนกุมภาพันธ์เตรียมจะ
ไป
เรียนจะมากรุงเทพฯท้าย
ก็จะไปถ่ายรูปเที่ยวานาจครูเอ๋เนี่ยอยู่
คู๋อยู่
กรุงเทพฯโคเรียมอยู่ที่ไหนคะเตรียมอยู่
ที่มหาสารคามค่ะหน้าอ้าผู้เตรียมอยู่
มหาสารคามครูเอ๋อยู่
กรุงเทพฯได้ดูทีนะค่ะอันนี้
โอเคนะคะอันนี้กรุงเทพฯ
โค
รงเทพอะนี้ครูเอ๋คู๋
คู่เอ๋อยู่อยู่กรุงเทพฯโอเรียมอยู่
มหาศาลหาญคำ
เขียนถูกไหมเนี่ย
สา
พระ
ถาม ah  SA  M
ได้ถูกแล้วค่ะ
ใช่มั้ยคูเรียมเนี่ยอันนี้เรียมครูเรียม
เนี่ยอยู่
คูเรียมอยู่จังหวัดมหาสารคาม
นะฮะจังหวัดและอยู่
กรุงเทพฯอ่ะคุดต้องพูดไปกรุงเทพฯไป
กรุงเทพฯนะครูเรียมจะไป
กรุงเทพฯทั้งคู่เรียนพูดน่ะกูเอกก็พูดแม่
เลี้ยงม้ามาเพราะครูเอ๋อยู่
กรุงเทพฯก็ต้องบอกครูเรียมมามา
กรุงเทพฯถ้าคูเรียร์ปลากรุงเทพฯนิโคเรียม
มาแล้วก็
เจอกับครูเอ๋
[เพลง]
เจอกับครูเอ๋โอเคสองคนไปทำคลิปด้วยกันนะ
ฮะโอเคมั้ยดีไหมคะดีไหมคะเนียนขึ้น Daily
Life
แต่กูเอมมีเวลาเฉพาะวันเสาร์คูเรียม
[เพลง]
ต้องบอกครูเรียมกูเองมีเวลาวันเสาร์อ่ะ
เป็นวันที่มีเวลา 1 วัน
ยังคิดว่าคิดว่าโอเคนะคะเพราะเรียมเรียม
คิดว่าจะไป
ไปเจ็บวันงอกคูณเลียมวันอาทิตย์โอเค
วันอาทิตย์ธรรมดาครูเอ๋ทำคลิปกับคู่เรียม
า
เอ้อใช่
[เพลง]
มั้ย
วุฒิตื่นเต้นตื่นเต้นนักเรียนคะรอนะคะรอ
ปรุงเรียมมา
กรุงเทพฯราคาเราจะทำคลิป
เดินไปดูไปด้วยกันเย้
ครูเอ๋จะพาโคเรียมไปที่ไหนไม่รู้ไม่รู้กู
เรียมอยากไปเยาวราชไหมอยากไปเรียมอยากชอบ
ยังชอบถ่ายรูป
เยาวราชสวยมากค่ะ
นิกานต์คืนนะคะคุณเรียงใช่ค่ะ
โยราชกลางคืนกูเรียนไม่ไปกลางวันเหรอคะ
อ่ะ
ต่อ
ไปค่ะ
ที่เยาวราชกลางวันก็จะคนเยอะเลยค่ะมีคนคน
ๆเยอะแรงวันคนน้อยกว่ากลางคืน
กลางคืนมีคนมากๆไปกิน
กินอาหาร
กลางวัน
ตอนกลางวันคนไม่กินอาหารหรอคะตัวเอง
เหมือนกันพูดเรื่องต้องไปดู
กลางวันจะเป็นคนที่ไปซื้อซื้ออาหาร
เป็นคนที่ไปไหว้ไหว้พระอ่า
ซื้ออาหารแล้วก็กลับบ้าน
แล้วก็กินอาหารแต่กลางคืนเป็นคนไปเที่ยว
ต่อ
ไปแล้วสวยสวยสวยๆ
ไว้เหมือนกัน
ไปเที่ยวแล้วก็ไปถ่ายรูปถ่ายในรูปกิน
อาหาร
คุย
[เพลง]
จนกลางวันคนไปซื้อกลับบ้าน
ไม่ถูกไม่คุยกัน
คุย
นิดหน่อย
ปาร์ตี้ไปใช่ปาร์ตี้อ๋อเพราะว่ากลางวัน
ร้อนใช่ไหมคะสวรรค์ร้อนค่ะร้อน
กลางคืนกลางคืนสบายๆชัดกลางคืนมันมืด
อันนี้ดีกว่าเปิดปุ๊บก็มืดแบบนี้ค่ะแบบ
นี้
รื่นล่ะเธอกิตัวเลขมี background มืดไม่
ได้
ขอโทษค่ะขอโทษเถอะ
ก็กลางคืนก็จะเป็น
อีก
อารมณ์หนึ่งอ้ะคือจะรู้สึก
กลางวันเอ่อ shopping  shopping  shopping
อ่าซื้อ
ๆเรียงคิดว่าครูเอ๋ออกไปช้อปปิ้งไปซื้อ
ซื้อเสื้อ
ของกินค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ไม่ชอบช็อปปิ้งเสื้อผ้า
หน้า Who  ate ชอบช้อปปิ้งอ่ะอะไรนะคะ
เป็น
หนังสือ
หนังสือแล้วก็ของกินนะไม่ไม่ไม่ช็อปปิ้ง
เสื้อผ้ามากๆขอ
ดูหนังสือ
หนังสือ
หนังสือคู่เอกไปซื้อมาจากที่ไหนคะอ๋อถ้า
หนังสือจะซื้อที่ร้านหนังสือค่ะร้าน
หนังสือร้านหนังสือก็องเชียร์บุ๊คอ่ะนาย
End  in ชื่ออนิดชื่อร้านหนังสือมี
เอเชียบุ๊คดวงกมล decay  Book ในอินอาจ
จุฬาเกจ c  f  c  f
มีร้านหนังสืออ่ะหืมครูเอ๋เดินเข้าร้าน
หนังสือ
ทำไมคะเงินหมดจากเงินไว้นักเรียนเงินเงิน
ไทยก็ปาดเงินญี่ปุ่นก็เย็นเงินเอามาลิกา
ก็ดอลลาร์เงินยุโรปก็ยูโรสีเหลืองปอนด์
ปอนด์เงินก่อนเงินอ่ะ
อังกฤษไม่รู้เรื่องไม่รู้ไม่ได้ขอโทษนะ
วันนี้ครูเอ๋นอนนิดหน่อย
เตรียมต้องเหมือนเหมือนกับครูเอ๋ค่ะถ้า
เทียมเจิญเดินเข้าร้านหนังสือ
ตายื่นจ่ายเงินเยอะมากๆ
เงินปอนด์ประเทศอะไรกูอีกแล้วก็อยากรู้
อังกฤษขอโทษ
เงินอังกฤษนั้นปอนด์นะเงินปอนด์
ก็คนไทยพูดเงินปอนด์นะก่อน
ก็คูเรียมก็เข้าร้านหนังสือไม่ได้
เอาเงิน
นี้นะ
เงินหมดใช่ไหมหนังสือเงินหมดแล้วครูเอ๋ก็
เอาหนังสือกลับมาที่บ้านเยอะมากๆ
กูเอ๋น่ะท่านเดินเดินเดินร้านหนังสือน่ะ
อยู่ได้ 1 ชั่วโมง2ชั่วโมง3ชั่วโมง
4ชั่วโมง 5 ชั่วโมง
แล้วก็เงินไม่บาย
แบบถ้าไปช้อปปิ้งเสื้อผ้าน่ะเดินๆ 1
ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงเหนื่อยแล้วเงินอยู่ที่
นี่
ไม่ช้อปปิ้งเสื้อฮ่าๆอาจจะ 1 ตัวแล้วล่ะ
แต่ถ้ากูเองไปร้านหนังสือไป
ก็อาจรู้จักตลาดไว้นักเรียนถ้าขอนักเรียน
ก็อาจจะไปอะไรโลตัส Tesco
คริสโตโลตัสไปซื้อ
ซื้อเวลาซื้อปลา
ปลาซื้อหมูฝอยๆเหมือนไหม
[เพลง]
รู้เหรอเนี่ยถ้าไป
ตลาดไท
ตลาดคนไทย
ครูเอ๋จ่ายเงิน
มีคลิปหน้า
แต่ไม่ใช่ที่นี่นะคะมีคลิปไปตลาดคนไทย
แล้วก็จ่ายซื้อ
ซื้อมากๆ
ชอบซื้อหนังสือแล้วก็ซื้ออาหาร 2 อย่าง
ค่ะเดี๋ยว
กูเลี้ยงล่ะชอบ
ชอบซื้อหนังสือ
เหมือนกันกับครูเอ๋แล้วก็ไม่ชอบซื้อเสื้อ
เสื้อตัวนี้ก็มีคนอื่นคนอื่นเอามาให้
เรียง
อันนี้สามีไข้
บางทีเพื่อนให้กูเอกก็ไม่ค่อยซื้อเสื้อ
ใช่ฮะเหมือนกันเลย
เรียงก็คิดถ้าเกิดเรียงจะซื้อเสื้อเหลือง
ก็ไม่อยากไม่อยากเลือกไม่อยากเลือกเรียน
คิดว่ามันเสียเวลาให้ปวดหัว
ใช่ปวดหัวปวดหัว
ซื้อเสื้อซื้อกางเกงปวดหัวๆแต่ถ้าหนังสือ
เย้
ปี
มี 1 ครั้งครูเรียมเดี๋ยวจะบอกค่ะ
คู๋นะอ่าเดี๋ยวนะคะกูเห็นลบนี้ก่อนนะคะรอ
อ่ะโอเคมีมีเพื่อนเพื่อนคนหนึ่ง
กุ้ยสีดำค่ะเพื่อน
เกย์ A มีอะไรนะมีมุกแฟร์
แฟร์ก็พาไปหน่อยคือเพื่อนไม่รู้จักที่
นั่นก็ให้เอ๋พาไป
ไม่ซื้อนะไม่ซื้อ
เดี๋ยวเก๋เอมไม่ไปเพราะว่าถ้าเอ๋ไปเอ็งจะ
ซื้อนั่นน่ะเหรอก็ไม่ไปแต่เพิ่มเพื่อน
อยากไปเอ๋ไปหน่อย 2 คนก็ไปมีเพื่อนเนี่ย
มีคิด
หนังสือหนังสือหนังสือ
คู๋เนี่ยไม่คิด
แต่พอไปสองคนไปที่
book  fair ตรงอันศูนย์สิริกิตประชุม
แห่งชาติสิริกิติ์
ชื่อนะคะชื่อศูนย์ประชุมแห่งชาติสิริกิต
อยู่ตรงนี้ที่อยู่
MRT
อะไรนะคะ
สุขุมวิท
อันนี้อโศกถ้าบีทีเอสก็ bts
อโศก
[เพลง]
แล้วก็ให้ MRT  MRT เมาเขาขอโทษขอโทษ MRT
ตรงนี้สุขุมวิทแล้วก็ MRT ตรงไปศูนย์
สิริกิตเลยใช่ค่ะเมื่อมี MRT ตรงนี้
เราก็ขึ้นได้เลย
จะเดินเดินแล้วก็จะเจอ
[เพลง]
ศูนย์สิริกิตร 5 รุ่น
ศูนย์สิริกิตคู๋ลิขิต 0 ไม่ซื้อไม่ซื้อ
แต่คู่เอกเดินๆ
20 นาทีด้วยวะ
20 นาที
a ซื้อกี่เล่มค่ะ
ซื้อสำคัญจะ 3 คัน 500 บาทบ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]
ที่สาธารณะบาทไปแล้ว
แล้วเพื่อนเพื่อนของตัวเอซื้อกี่บาท
ยังไม่ซื้อแต่กูเองอ่ะ 3,500 บาท
[เพลง]
แล้วก็พอเดินเดินๆอีกวันนั้นครูเอ๋หมด
เงินเข้าไหร่
ชอบเรียงชอบ
กูเอกคิดไม่ซื้อแต่พอเดินดู
ก่อน
มีหนังสือ 1 เซตราคา 15,000 บาทครูเรียม
หนังสือนะมีพืชหรือ 1 เซต
ใช่มีหนังสือหนึ่งทำเสร็จเลยค่ะ
1000 บาทสีหลายๆเล่ม
ใช่
โอ๊ยหนังสือดีมากกรีดซื้อใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่มีงาน
เวลา
หนังสือ
อยากได้อยากได้อยากได้อยากได้ดูหนังสือ
ไม่ได้หรอกอยากได้
หน้า
เอกก็ได้เยอะหายเยอะอยู่ 7,000 บาทหมด
แล้วก็สบายใจ
ไม่มีเงินกินข้าวแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเอ๋ถ้าคุณเอ๋กับเรียมเจอกันครูเอก
ก็ไปร้านหนังสือกับเหวี่ยวด้วยออ
โอเคไหม
นักเรียนนักเรียนคิดว่าครูเรียมกับ
ครูเอ๋ไปร้านหนังสือดีดีหรือไม่ดีไม่ดี
โคเรียมต้องมีเขียนเอาไว้นะอันนี้ซื้อ
ต้องคิดเค้ก 1,000 บาทซื้อ
พอ
พ่อ
อะไรอ๋อ
รีบขอใบพอกูเอกก็ต้องมีเทคนิคไม่ไปออกไป
ปากตาเทไปไปเยาวราชก็ได้
ไปเยาวราชโอเคไปอะไรนะแป๊ะ Bangkok  Art
Center โอเคมั้ยโอเคโอ๊ยตื่นเต้นเมื่อ
วานเมื่อวานครูเรียมควงเอ๋ไปคุณเอกให้ดู
ขอ
ให้ดูเดี๋ยวนะรอแป๊บนึงรอแป๊บนึง
จะได้ไหมครูเรียนจะดูได้ไหมเดี๋ยวคุยให้
ดู
หน่อยอีกนิดหน่อยให้หน่อย
นิดนึงนะเกลือนักเลยนะรอนิดนึงนะคะหน้ารอ
นิดนึง
สภาเรียมไปใช่มั้ยใช่ใช่ๆ
มีค่ะกูเหลี่ยมเดี๋ยวกู f เปิดให้ดูได้
นักเรียนจะได้เห็น
สักครู่นะคะมี
โอกาส Center
ไอติมมังคุดทำไปกินเนี้ยอร่อยโอ้ย
เอาไอติมหมา
ออกไปเร็วๆหมดแล้วหรอเท่าไหร่คะถ้าซื้อ
จ่ายเท่าไหร่
ไอติมอ่ะไอติมของคู๋
100 เท่าไหร่ 100 กว่าบาทค่ะ
ประมาณ
136  15
ฟรีหากมีคนไก่กันให้ครูเอ๋
ดีมากๆ
คนนี้เค้าดิเออ
รูปพลอยหรอคะ
กูกูเองไอ้ติมฟรี
[เพลง]
ขอบคุณค่ะกูปล่อยนี่ๆซอมบี้
จะไปหาครูพลอยคงพลอย
เขาเป็นแบบนี้ค่ะเป็นอะไรนะโป็นัด
ไม่รู้อาจอะไรกูเอกก็ไม่เข้าใจแต่เป็นโค
วิชตอนนี้ใช่ไหมคะขอก็เลยชาร์จแบบโควิช
คู่เอกก็เลยทำ
เป็นเหมือนซอมบี้
ให้มันซอมบี้จริงๆเยอะ
[เพลง]
งู
กินเยอะไปนะดูครูเอ๋แบบสนุกมากๆๆ
ขอโทษค่ะขอโทษค่ะพร้อมแล้วค่ะหิวข้าว
กูเกิลเสนอตัว
[เพลง]
มีเฮก็ไม่รู้ใช่ไหมว่าถ่ายรูปได้กูเองก็
เลยดูแล้วก็ไม่ถ่ายรูปก็เดินเดินๆเดิน
ขึ้นข้างบนแบบพอรู้ถ่ายรูปได้ที่ดูเสร็จ
แล้วไม่ได้ถามอ๋อเตรียมคิดว่าครูเอกเดิน
เดินเดินลงมาข้างล่าง
เดิน
เหนื่อยมาก
จริงๆต้องขึ้นข้างบนแล้วก็เดินเดินเดินลง
ใช่ไหมคะแต่คู๋เดินข้างล่างแล้วขึ้นข้าง
บนเอกก็จะเหนื่อยสองคนเหนื่อยมาก
เหนื่อยจริงๆครูเรียมเคยไปไหมคะ
กระเทียมเตรียมคิดว่าเคยไปเมื่อก่อนแต่
ว่าเขาจะเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนไปไม่เปลี่ยนทุก
1เดือน2เดือน3เดือนไม่รู้ค่ะเปลี่ยนนะคะ
ถ้านักเรียนมานะคะไปดูนะคะอะดูได้เดิน
เดินสนุกมากใช่เดินมากๆแล้วก็จะเหนื่อย
The เดินๆมากๆเราก็กินไอศครีมเออ
เดินมากๆแล้วก็กินช็อกโกแลตโอเคโอเค
ค่ะป้าจะการค่ะครูเอ๋ Fake คู่เอกกับครู
เรียมก็ไปก่อนนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเจอกันในคลิปหน้านะคะค่า
สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋บ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
ได้ไหม
ม.ค